japan has not only done this for
valentine's day they've done it for like
christmas they've done it for like
halloween
yeah they've done it for everything
they've just completely somehow
made everything like a million times
more complicated than it should be
as if life here isn't stressful enough
yeah right with all the [ __ ]
paperwork you got to fill out for
everything
and then and then you got [ __ ] like you
know or sayable and all two again which
is like
giving gifts at like certain times of
the year and [ __ ]
to people and just see this this is why
i'm glad that we don't we don't work
exactly in an office environment oh no
like we
we work with people who you know
understand foreign culture and
everything like that so i don't have to
because if i'm working in the japanese
company i'd be so [ __ ] stressed out
about that
not even my work right yeah just kidding
like not [ __ ] up like imagine going
to a company party or going to like a
company drinking session
and you just don't know how to act yeah
because that's that's me right
like only in japan will you go to the
office and you're more stressed out
about your like social status than you
are the actual work that you're involved
in like i'm stressed enough thinking am
i giving
my business card the right way oh yeah
you know because there's rules
after that yeah i just want to like swap
business cards but no it's like is it
pointed the right way
am i i'm like we have to giving it we
have to give it at the same time
i had the situation where i had to give
my business cards recently and i
had a mailing was there so i had like a
100 iq move i'm like i don't know my
manager will do it
i'm not but he's just like i'm like i'm
like i'm like i don't i'm gonna give my
business card my manager will give you
[Music]
it's the opposite for me because she
knows that i can speak japanese right
now so she waits for me to go first but
like in reality i've just forgotten my
business card
i don't carry them with me man because i
don't want to [ __ ] carry them
because it's because you have to have a
separate business card holder and i've
not gotten to the point
yeah where i i have enough business
meetings where i could be
like um networking at any point of time
and it just looks tacky
if you just pull out your business card
and it's in in like your beaten ass
wallet yeah with 20
stuff and yeah with 20 other million
cards and there's that that just doesn't
look cool yeah yeah you know what yeah
[ __ ] rule i found out the other day
in japan uh if i want to leave my
apartment building for more than two
weeks i need to get permission
oh yeah yeah yeah is it two is it more
than two weeks for you for us it's a
month
more than two weeks i got it like
permission to leave my house
oh yeah that is that is you do know why
that's the case though right why is that
the case it's because there's a lot of
cases in japan of people
running away and they leave the house
basically they basically
escape well no
because the guarantor if the guarantor
can't chase you up then maybe the game
does to pay
right it's not the whole point no no you
you you send the money to the guarantor
and then the guarantor has to pay but if
you're not sending any money to the
guarantor then the guarantor can't do
anything
oh i thought the whole point was the
guarantor pays if you can't pay uh
that's if the guarantor is nice enough i
i guess i can understand if they're
worried about that but then also i don't
know it's just weird
living in the uk where you i don't know
it just seems like i'd never want to
have to ask if i can leave
yeah sure that's weird you have to ask
permission to do everything
two weeks that seems like a little month
i can kind of understand yeah yeah yeah
i mean yeah so yeah so like every time
aki and i go to like the us for example
like yeah
like last year like before the whole
dynamic thing where we were in
america for like three months at a time
or something i have to call them up i
mean it's super easy
i i i can imagine them they never say no
no
but it's just weird though that they
might say like
no you can't go well i mean for us it's
easy because i just say oh it's for work
and they're like okay
yeah yeah i don't question it you know
but if it's like you know i have to
attend an anime convention then maybe
they'll be like
all right if they were like grilling you
i'd be like mind you on [ __ ] business
i pay you
yeah yeah like oh my gosh dude
i remember so few comments like man
conor [ __ ] hates japan why is he
living there
he's so ungrateful man and it's like no
i want to
privilege because we i guess we do often
point out the things that we don't like
about japan a lot but that's because i
think
a lot of people in my mind view japan as
this like utopian country yeah
and at the end of the day it's like any
other country has issues and also yeah
and also because you know i think that
we've experienced living here as opposed
to just listening here you can't get a
scope of a country just from visiting it
i mean like we have complaints about any
country yeah we're british i mean i'm
going to complain about anything
i'll find a complaint with something i
love
i love it but [ __ ] i hate it